all right so uh I'm going to address
your question and we'll note the
following things we've already seen and
discussed and demonstrated okay so if
we're here in
y okay I want to uh seize her center
from where we at I'm not just here in
the house I seize the center from
wherever I'm at and then I can move her
from her Center can move her any old way
okay Center
move it's not a matter of taking her
elbow and turning her you just move
her okay so it's
just from
here in her Palm at the contact seizing
her Center moving her Center
okay so we'll try that they're going to
try that here that's the first thing to
know premise number one right so this is
premise 1 a okay so it's not that go
ahead and get in stance please okay it's
not that she has spinal displacement
push me please and I get out of the
way nor in any way she's pushing and I
get out of the way that's what happening
okay so if she's pulling now she's
pulling
okay the only difference is that the
grounding foot is going to be the front
foot in this case because of how I'm
standing but the seizure is still the
same
boom okay and so you usually we'll see
like I if I if I'm
pulling then you see it's all here in
the grip okay whereas if I push and she
grounds there's a little seizure there
but it's really
external uh in the sense that what we're
using is like we said on the weapons
video how do you get IE adhesion on a
weapons video well if you if you get
enough Yong toy pressure you generate a
kind of pseudo I which is the increase
in friction as we understand it okay but
as Virginia noted that night you don't
really have the center okay and that's
what we're experiencing here so if I
press hard on her and she gets an
external bracing
angle there's a kind of friction here
and she can kind of move that but you
can still feel it it's more in my hands
but once I start doing the other way she
can't get it because I'm not really
generating that external pressure so
we're going to let our people try this
now we'll go to premise two and what we
learned from premise one is that I can
seize the
center at touch okay so we're going to
expand upon that we also learned in 1 a
that it doesn't it's not about them
pushing getting out of the way or them
pushing and be generating a y y CL
conflict that I can then simulate I to
okay so here she has no grip her fingers
are open she could hold wherever
okay he holds wherever and I find the
same connection toenter and we're just
here and here
and again I'm not looking for skeletal
or bone or anything like that just w't
we move this
way okay so we'll try uh premise 2 okay
this is what is happening in premise one
it's just
masquerade or
deceivingly
hidden by our egoic mind that sees
fingers gripping okay the the adhesion
is inside the grip okay I'm not relying
on them holding on to me when I hear and
seize the center so premise two uh
premise 2
a okay so it might
seem that she's not spinally displacing
she's not pushing okay and this is where
you have to realize what an adhesion is
and it is a
equivalency between her
y aspect that's made up of her forward
momentum her
materiality gravity her inertia all that
is y aspect and when that is equated
with what I call alchemically treated
Yong that's y that goes down and comes
back out it's infus us with
yin and it equals her value we get stuck
here there's a there's an adhesion okay
at the contact
point it's not that she a lot of people
will think like why can't she slide
forward well she could if I'm less if
I'm Yin she could slide forward she can
slide
forward can do it every time okay or I'm
greater
I'll slip so if uh when she tries to
slide
forward I will match that and we get
stuck so she's trying and I had to
increase to keep the equivalency okay
it's not that she's just touching me
just touching me and like the modern UK
who gets like a Dr Pony and walks over
there okay that's not what's happening
so she I'm stuck on there she can't go
she can't go forward it's not that she's
pushing in on me it's not that she is
let's say so that would be premise 2A
she's stuck open your hand don't use
your fingers at all okay and she's
trying
to go forward she can't go forward you
see she can't go forward I'm matching it
she feels friction there so I'm going to
play with the equation and the camera's
going to come close so they can see my
skin and I'm going to demonstrate the
the friction in my skin
okay so she's not moving
in I will go to her she's trying to push
forward she's trying to push
forward and you can see go back just
make a contact at first so my skin is
there and as she goes and I match that
you can see my skin is stretching do you
see see okay we'll do it again we'll
watch this hand right here we'll just do
one hand for now okay there we are
there's my skin in place she's not
gripping we're just lightly touching and
as I feel her go forward I press that
and it gets stuck okay premise 2 a
doesn't change if she goes back the
other way so if I'm loose she'll slip
but if I match it we're stuck and I can
move her in so premise 2
a premise uh 2 a was her trying to go
forward and I'm not letting her go
forward premise 2 b i match it and I'm
stuck on the inside premise to
C we're here and she going to try to
open she going to come off that's what a
lot of people will do is when they
realize their stuck they're going to try
to create space all you have to do is
follow it follow it no it's not going to
change anything okay if I stay here she
goes off then we'll break but if she
goes out I follow and you'll hit it okay
that'll be premise 2 C we'll do all a b
and c try so in premise one inside the
grip I have an adhesion in premise 2 I'm
exposing that letting it be known okay
and how is it working
right we also introduced the follow
stick so they will try to get off but in
them trying to get off that's because
you created a dilemma I have control of
your center from the adhesion point you
as an athlete are going to know that
you're going to try to pull off of the
contact Point what do what do you do
then you follow the guy find the next uh
adhesion Point that's what you do okay
um but you made them in that moment that
they're trying to get off and they're
trying to regain their Center they're
not being offense do you see he's trying
to regain his Center he's in kazushi
he's trying to regain control of his
person that means I now have the
initiative okay don't expand this stuff
to like now you're now now you won cuz
you're superum adhering iky Master it
doesn't work like that so uh she comes
in grab with whatever boom end the
freaking fight
that that was it okay that that is how
that functions so she gets stuck I use
the adhesion to project create distance
draw my weapon and I shoot her in the
face okay that that's the Marshall
application here this this is not the
Marshall
application that is not it okay so don't
don't blow it out just stick with our
premises here
okay let's go over here where we
were premise
three there is no reason why I need to
be
gripped there's no reason why I need to
wait for the grip I can adhere at any
point it also can adhere at any point in
time and any point on her body so it
doesn't have to be here in her
Palm so we've done this before uh she's
coming in to grab and my
counter and I am on my counter on this
one I'm on the outside here and on the
inside here and we're stuck again I find
the
center here you come I
counter TR not to set up for me just
grab and you didn't get
it okay so that's going to be uh premise
three I don't need to be on her Palm I
don't need to be on her forearm I can be
anywhere where I want to be and find an
adhesion has nothing to do with the grip
the Palm or the forarm okay let's try
that fromis four making our way to the
technique
kiten
okay um just stay where you're at don't
move so if I was to punch her with mun
SK I would need enough spinal
penetration with the stripe to displace
her and that's generally going to
be a little bit past your
spine oh I don't want to kiss the
surface and I don't want to hit the
midsection in munet get you can have
reasons for doing that minimal
penetration but M skip proper you are
trying to hit boom
and displacer okay so come
back so I'm going to do that same thing
and we also don't extend the elbow past
katatori okay so that's where I'm
at and I'm going to figure out I'm going
to reverse engineer where my front foot
is for mun
get okay come back where you were
let's find it again put your toes on the
line we're going to scientifically do
it okay so my toes on the line now I
only only given One
Step boom she's on the line and you can
see how close we are for munet SK okay
we are
not out
here okay
it doesn't make sense I don't know why
that ever started that's goofy as hell
because on katata
D that Target is closer to me and I
start about here
step but now the target is back
here therefore my one step should have
me
closer you see
make sense okay
so these mats are traditional to Tommy
length
so one width is 1
meter I'm just a little over half of a
meter away from her on my body size okay
so the drill here is get a little over
half a meter they're just standing in
chenai and oh
displace them without hyperextending
your elbow okay let's try that back
onai little over half a meter away from
me and premise
five
watch the path of action of the munet G
so the fist starts
neutral and then the elbows brought back
and the fist went up from the elbow
coming back and when the punch goes
through there's an upward this to the
punch as the elbow re
extends does not start from back here
you should have already punched him in
the face it starts
neutral it goes back and comes up
and as the elbow
extends the hand will come up as the
shoulder becomes the articulation angle
okay so
munis first goes
back and up then in and up more okay so
we're going to do Discovery
learning they're going to observe that
path to action and you are going to feel
that path of action
boom okay premise
five from the six again working our way
towards k n when it's
get the
uh other hand here is a
teming and it is to the veins and
arteries on this neck
and um it's not
displacing it's
percussive and closer to the surface
attacking those veins and arteries okay
so meaning it's
not
here he is also coming
in in the
attack he has forward
inertia you
there is a hinge here that's why his
chin can
drop energy is going to be absorbed in
that
hinge I am not trying to displace his
spine this becomes a very percussive
strike where he feels it but his body is
not sagittally displaced okay so he's
going to walk in
which is not even close to mun ski speed
but you'll see the the
weapon okay that's the weapon so they're
going to feel that okay they're just
going to walk in I'll do this can I just
walk in and he hits that okay I feel it
more
like but it's not really displacing me
does that make sense okay so we but it
is it does alter your Consciousness cuz
your Vagas nerve is going should I pass
out should I I'm not quite sure okay
and I just need the should I the
techniques over by the rest of that
sentence okay as far as your Vegas nerve
is concerned all right so they're going
to try that as you try this don't try
that many times you don't need a million
times to do it just want to feel that he
doesn't go
flying okay let's try it okay and we're
on premise seven
she's going to get
in uh H for the munet ski and then the
Moet ski she's going to attack my front
foot and we're going to go really slow
okay when she brings her elbow back
that's your Yin phas and that's when you
enter you don't
enter on the Y
facee on the Y phas I'm in
and I am not going to push down on the
upward phase of that I'm just seeking
contact that is all I'm doing
okay so as she
enters in and then just resting just
resting you have the
adhesion it's like this drow just like
that
drow and now reach and make contact
when you enter on the Y face make light
contact that's all you're doing
[Music]
okay okay uh for
contrast
Taylor my teacher would do it like
[Music]
this okay and it's like that was
Okay so all I'm doing is
[Music]
here that's with this
hand okay very light okay
try okay so in that in that timing in
what we were doing I popped the hand
sword so he goes
in this hand doesn't get heavy doesn't
try to do that it just
hit again he
again hit again
hits hits okay that hand is light there
you can't go after like in the last
drill when you had no ATT in your way
back here it has to
hit at the positive angle here as I keep
moving through and it's very light here
okay
so let's try that
one all right so my teachers uh my
teachers understanding of the technique
was when they come up with that ski slam
the hell out of it down right and shove
their head down you
see and uh to me it's clearly not I you
cuz you have a young young clash as
you're going up when it goes
down and then I reaching up here and I'm
trying to shove your head down you
see that's her inertia does not want to
go down so we don't want to do that
okay so remember that her hand is going
up
okay and my hand was on top but not
pushing in the last two
premises but as you start to feel her
hand go up will start low elbow tight as
her hand starts to go up that's what I
start to take this way you see and use
my your 90
fluctuation so we're going to do this
drill this way I'm going to get already
in place and I'm going to go
here and here I get an adhesion whatever
adhesion I got so Sean come
close on this side
and we'll watch your skin I'll
demonstrate it at the skin level that's
where I'm at okay there's friction there
and there's friction here okay as she
starts to come up and I use those two to
move her into that curve you
see it's no different than when I moved
her from her Center into this curve
right here she energy comes up and I
move her into the Curve
I am not pushing against this I'm
equalizing it and as she start a little
lower cuz you're going to come up okay
as she comes up that upward energy that
I feel I don't shove it down I turn
it okay that's our next premise try lost
track of which premise we're on so
whatever okay again like the earlier
ones it's not that she's coming up and I
start to push down and I get some sort
of external friction that it's just
that's the cue okay it's not necessary
so for example she could not come up
just relax woman okay she could just be
there and you're going to still stick do
you see because you can stick anywhere
okay doesn't doesn't matter so if Johan
didn't see it I'm just here and I just
stick here
likewise uh she could be pulling
backwards she could be like trying to
back
up we're going to get stuck okay so
we'll try that one okay one no upper
pressure which is the Q when you do it
and then two they're trying to pull back
off of it okay try Okay so we're on the
next premise we know at a certain
point that the punch is going to
elongate the left
to here right we know that okay and as
it does that the disin becomes more Yin
it's get gets so lift up so example go
back relax relax stop trying to think
about what I'm telling you to do okay
just do what I say so here her fist is
back and close to her body her elbows
closed don't let me push it down don't
let me change it position positioning in
space from there to here don't let me do
it got
it okay extend it out and don't let me
change it from here let me move it let
me move it to here don't let me do
that you see because it's further away
from her body you get it so it has a Yin
face going by
Ro a Yang face coming
out and then it's re-entering its Yin
phase again
okay and so that means as it comes out I
am going to start moving her this way in
the
spiral but as it comes away from her
body I also finish your punch I let it
go down too
okay do you guys understand that got
that that's the timing of when to do it
okay so as you
experience the
inertia of her
posture of her front
foot as her penetration in ttention you
will feel different levels of Y that
don't want you to take it down you don't
want to do what my teacher did just
shove straight across it you continue to
bring it
out at 90
fluctuations
as you bring it
down and it gets really
light
okay you can you can uh guess like I
don't know there's no way of knowing but
she could tell you if my hand is doing
my teacher's thing or whether my hand is
just
[Music]
super
light what do you say it feels light at
the beginning and then heav okay well
that's not what I wanted but okay you're
you I'll do it with my finger okay so
she
goes here's the adhesion out
and it's just my finger so whatever felt
heavy to her it couldn't actually been
that heavy for me to apply it does feel
heavy to the UK but I'm not really
applying that great strength if you were
to feel that you were applying a great
strength you were in a y y contestation
you need to go more
around in order to go more down okay
that's how that works um so that's our
next experiment I start here and as
she's going it goes out that's where I
take that down okay let's try
that if you we're back on the last dral
so as her hand goes out and I started
going this way then it gets light and I
move it around we're going to watch her
head her head is this high off the
ground all that
happens her head gets lower
we now combine the other adhesion okay
out it all comes lower there's her head
head went under my hand I did not shove
like my
teacher try to shove her down okay I
bring her head to me so
in so again to her like she can't pick
her head up she won't be able to pick
her head up you feel like that's strong
but I'll do it with my
finger okay so we'll add that now okay
question the
mechanisms are the same we always do
there's the iy
hand you got to seize the center moving
the center and turning the whole body I
can stick from wherever I'm at
externally I have to match yin and yang
okay I'm not a fan of how a lot of taii
people will just
root and contest and say it's an
internal yield I believe that
concentrically the reconciliation of Y
and yangong that is happening internally
should happen externally because I know
martially you can't just do an internal
reconciliation doesn't work athletes
will just deal with that Force as any
other Force
and you're caught on the line of attack
with your hands down okay it's
stupid um the last part
is or the second part of your question
is how much energy it's like there's I'm
trying to do no energy okay just enough
to stick so the energy is equal to her
but it's at 90 fluctuation so as far as
my output is it's very light I don't
feel anything so traditionally I've
heard different values they say it's
about 2 lb of pressure about 4 lbs of
pressure but you already know that's
because the Chinese didn't use
the pound system okay that's a British
thing um or an English thing or an
eventually an American thing and it's
like no and they didn't use the metric
system whatever it is it's very
light okay it shouldn't if if I ever
felt like I actually had to Ump
something I would F follow the next un
space I wouldn't I wouldn't contest like
that okay like my teacher
did um okay the last thing you do and
which is highly covered in that video
you link is I got to do all that I just
did and set up the x
pattern uh so that means I got to be in
the middle of her
spiraling traversing through the
sagittal plane such that the young hand
is going to run into to her inertia that
I internalize and project okay so and we
get in her her stance she goes to strike
I do that whole thing and as I bring her
forward this is the front inward kazushi
that's where that's going to be right
there I
[Music]
need this Hound to hit her inertia so
just rewind the film where you were
rewind
okay as she comes
in the iky hand has to bring her around
into that
pattern and you will feel the force
increase on that
hand okay I don't know where you need to
be maybe over here maybe
okay she's going in and you can you're
going to feel that it's pressure do you
see eventually it gets light right
here's light and then it got heavy again
at the end you see that as it's passing
through its phases so I'm not going to
throw her but I'll displace her a little
as she
feels that okay that's what you're doing
now the scaredy cat UK is going to feel
that we'll come to here and when they
feel the center they kind of absorb it
they feel that projecting so let me show
the projection first okay the projection
is right
there they absorb it by taking energy
away you see that so as they do that you
follow it in and you take the next
projection point which is the HP and out
there go okay they're going to try that
now that's going to be the end of our
video let us know if you have questions
okay thank you